did you spot the two and zealans in the
most recent trailer have you heard that
a Back to the Future star will
reportedly make an appearance here's
everything you need to know about the
Mandalorian season 3 before the big
Premiere the wait for the Mandalorian
season 3 is almost over at Brazil's ccxp
in December 2022 it was announced that
the third season of the Disney plus Star
Wars series would be premiering on March
1st 2023 granted the stretch of time
between season 2 and season 3 has been
pretty long as the second season hit
Disney plus all the way back in October
2020 denjarin did of course continue his
journey in a few episodes of The Book of
Boba Fett alongside that titular
character but it's been a while since he
was front and center of his own show but
now his return is nigh of course if
you're itching for more Star Wars to
hold you over until then there's plenty
of content on Disney plus from other
Disney plus series to the actual Star
Wars movies themselves or it might be
the perfect time to go back and revisit
dinjaran's adventures in the first two
seasons of the Mandalorian there have
been two trailer drops thus far which
have undoubtedly wedded the appetites of
many fans from jarin's home world of
Mandalore to grogu using the force to
throw an enemy we're all excited for
March 1st the Mandalorian season 3 will
feature a major change of scenery as
denjarin travels to his Homeworld of
Mandalore the planet of the mandalorians
jarin hasn't been on Mandalore since he
was a child there's no telling what the
journey will bring as we've only heard
stories of the war that destroyed the
once great planet and drove the
Mandalorian across the Galaxy in footage
screened at the 2022 Star Wars
celebration jarin says he's headed to
Mandalore to seek forgiveness for his
transgressions the worst of which was
him removing his helmet by choice in
order to rescue rogu then you are a
Mandalorian
no more
[Music]
there he'll have to bathe in a pool of
water in order to wash away his sins
speaking with IGN in September 2022
executive producer Rick famowiwa
confirmed that Mando grappling with his
season 2 decision would be a major part
of the upcoming installment he said
there are obviously repercussions that
come from the decisions we make he made
a decision for the child which will
continue to reverberate so part of that
is gonna be explored during the season
but a father will do anything for their
child of course things will get
complicated once denjarin returns to his
home world as we know he belongs to a
very specific sect of mandalorians who
never remove their helmets the children
of the watch however that doesn't apply
to most other mandalorians something
showrunner John Favreau elaborated on
while talking to the Dagobah dispatch
podcast he said now we know that there
are other groups of mandalorians where
they have different sets of rules and so
these different groups are coming
together the Nexus point for all of
those communities of course is their
home World from which they're exiled
which is Mandalore it probably won't
help matters that Mando is in possession
of the fabled dark saber a Legendary
Blade that Mandalorian leader Boca tan
Crees desperately wants to get her hands
on and of course the remnant of the
Galactic Empire will be working in the
shadows as the official plot synopnopsis
reads the new Republic struggles to lead
the Galaxy away from its dark history
the Mandalorian will cross paths with
old allies and make new enemies as he
and grogu continue their journey
together
all right kid hang on
you ready for an adventure never fear
Pedro Pascal is of course returning as
denjarin and he won't be the only
familiar actor coming back Giancarlo
Esposito will reprise his role as the
villainous moff Gideon Carl Weathers is
returning to play grief carga Katie
Sackhoff will be making things
interesting as Boca tan craze
additionally expect to see Amy Sedaris
as mechanic pelimoto Omid optahi as
Imperial scientist Dr Pershing and Paul
Sun Young Lee as New Republic pilot
Captain Carson Teva and of course we'll
get to hear the commanding voice of
Emily swallow as the armorer the leader
of dinjarans Mandalorian tribe of course
there will be plenty of new faces as
well and if you're a fan of Back to the
Future or Who Framed Roger Rabbit then
you have a lot to get excited about
according to the Hollywood Reporter
Christopher Lloyd will be showing up in
season 3 reportedly as a guest star it's
also been said via comicbook.com that
comedian Tim Meadows from Saturday Night
Live The Ladies Man and the Goldbergs
will make an appearance slash film has
also reported that taika waititi will be
returning to the series after having
played the Droid ig-11 in season one
this is acceptable ever since the first
season the Mandalorian has played host
to some of the most interesting
directors in the business like taika
waititi and Robert Rodriguez and over
the course of the show several
filmmakers have been invited back again
and again as they seem to have that
special something when it comes to
bounty hunting action and that emotional
Mando grogu Bond according to the
Hollywood Reporter rice Dallas Howard
will be directing an episode which makes
it the third she's contributed to the
series thus far the actor filmmaker
previously helmed season 1's sanctuary
and season two's the heiress griefcarga
himself will also be stepping back
behind the camera as Carl Weathers will
direct at least one episode previously
he directed season two's The Siege a
Mandalorian Mainstay will also be
calling the shots behind the camera Rick
famo yiwa will sit in the director's
chair for season three after helming
season ones the child and season twos
the believer famo yiwa is going to be
extremely busy this season as he was
also promoted to Executive Producer
alongside John Favreau and Dave filoni
as for newcomers Rachel Morrison has
joined the director's fold Morrison has
served as cinematographer on projects
like Fruitvale Station mudbound and dope
she also became the first woman to earn
an Oscar nomination for best
cinematography thanks to her work on
black panther Lee Isaac Chung is also
having a moment after directing the
moving Indie drama manari he was tapped
not only to helm the sequel to 1996's
twister but also at least one episode of
the Mandalorian season 3 plus Peter
Ramsey who co-directed and won an Oscar
for Spider-Man into the spider-verse
will also be directing denjarin on his
journey through a Galaxy a long time ago
per The Hollywood Reporter there are
many creative minds working behind the
scenes of the Mandalorian but if we had
to lay credit for the show at one
person's feet those shoes would belong
to John Favreau The Man Behind Iron Man
and elf kick-started the whole series
and he'll Remain the showrunner in
season three in fact he's been at work
on the new scripts for years with
variety reporting all the way back in
April 2020 that he'd been writing season
three for quite some time and while he
did pin most of the episodes by himself
he did receive some help on a few from
Noah Clore and Star Wars Mastermind Dave
filoni in addition to Leading the show
Favreau will be executive producing
alongside filoni and previous
Mandalorian director Rick famowiwa her
collider with this talented Trio at the
helm we expect the Mandalorian season 3
to raise the bar for what Star Wars TV
shows can be if there's one thing Star
Wars fans love it's digging into all the
fun little details on that note what
other little tidbits do we know about
season 3 of the Mandalorian well the
enzelans are coming back remember Babu
frick from the rise of Skywalker that's
an anzelin for those not in the Star
Wars no two of the little droidsmiths
pop up in the official trailer although
we're unsure if you either of them is
Babu Frick or if they're voiced by
original actor Shirley Henderson we've
also gotten glimpses of a tree filled
with kawakian monkey lizards so prepare
for a lot of obnoxious laughter it also
looks like the B1 battle droids are back
as these rather useless robots are seen
in the official trailer hanging out in
what appears to be a robo bar we've also
heard about some of the incredibly cool
ships that might factor into the
upcoming season according to
comicbook.com two new Lego sets
connected to the Mandalorian season 3
are dropping in May 2023 with one set
revealing a pirate snub fighter and
another revealing a Mandalorian Fang
Fighter versus a TIE Interceptor in fact
the official trailer seems to show this
exact scene in action additionally at
Brazil's Comic-Con experience in
December 2022 attendees received a
poster displaying some season 3 concept
art according to collider the poster
depicts the Mandalorian at Navarro the
desert world with a din Town run by
carga in season one however in the
poster the town now looks like a lush
Utopia indicating things have changed a
lot since the jaren's been away the
poster details seem to have been
confirmed in the official trailer where
we see karga's Community thriving we
also get a glimpse of what appears to be
the busy City planet of Coruscant and
the official trailer also shows a group
of Jedi in the Jedi Temple bracing for
what seems to be the onslaught of Order
66 and while we don't have any inside
info here it looks like somebody with a
lightsaber is trying to cut their way
through the Jedi Temple door indicating
that Anakin Skywalker could possibly be
making a comeback make things the way we
want them to be perhaps most
interestingly making Star Wars a source
that usually has pretty solid Star Wars
Scoops has said that snoke's praetorian
guard will be appearing in the
Mandalorian season 3. the same site has
also reported that we might see moff
Gideon wearing a horned Mandalorian
helmet and that Bo Katan might be
sporting armor made from a fallen
mythosaur these details aren't confirmed
but if they pan out they will be
absolutely incredible to see
[Music]